das thema reisen bleibt uns auch immer
treu auch quarantäne hat was mit reisen
zu tun
wir kommen zu dem fall von enke
fleschutz aus frankfurt die hat ärger
mit einem abgesagten flug und da gibt es
richtig zoff ich melde mich oder hab das
anliegen das wir januar und seinen flug
mit zwei kindern und mein mann gebucht
haben und würden wären nach ibiza
geflogen mit der condor jetzt hat mir
können oder ein zurückgeschrieben am 10
juli weil ich dann die frist war
abgelaufen und wollte nur beim geld
bleibt meine 866 euro
daraufhin schrieb mir dann condor wir
haben das geld schon am 18
juno annopol oder lesen wir sind mit der
sache fertig obwohl sagt immer wieder ja
wie geld müssen sie sich bitte an ihre
fluggesellschaft direkt wenden habe ich
ja und die haben es auch an opodo schon
überwiesen und obwohl überweist ist aber
nicht an mich ich hoffe sie kann mir
helfen vielen dank ja da kann ich
verstehen dass man da richtig sauer wird
wenn sie jetzt von einem zum nächsten
geschoben an kempkens wie ist da die
rechtslage also die rechtslage ist
zunächst einmal so dass mein
vertragspartner immer auch
ansprechpartner bleibt wer meinen
vertragspartner ist das sehe ich in den
reiseunterlagen die bekomme ich ja
zugeschickt und da steht dann drauf wäre
sozusagen im briefkopf überhaupt meinen
vertragspartner ist das heißt im grunde
genommen habe ich ja informationen
darüber wer das jetzt eingespielt hat
und wer sagen wir mal das inkasso macht
das ist auch ein ganz anderes thema
das ist nicht ganz so wichtig und bei
diesen reiseportalen ist es meistens so
die reiseportale machen vielleicht das
inkasso sowohl auf der einen seite also
auf der einnahmenseite als auch bei der
rückgabe seite aber vertragspartner
bleibt immer der reiseveranstalter also
schaue ich in den vertrag mehr als
veranstalter an den wende ich mich und
wenn der veranstalter dann sagt ich habe
das geld aber längst einen dritten
überwiesen
dann kann man ja sagen das geht nicht
überhaupt nichts an das ist mir auch
egal
ich habe meinen vertrag bahn und will
man von euch mein geld zurück bekommen
wir haben im moment die situation wie
wir sie gerade geschildert haben relativ
häufig das wird so hin und her so ping
pong spiel
er sagt er ein ich habe da schon
überwiesen und der andere sagt stimmt
nicht oder bekomme ich nicht oder was
auch immer
deshalb nicht hin und her schicken
lassen denn man kann ja diese angaben
gar nicht kontrollieren wenn in diesem
fall beispielsweise condor sagte evans
an opodo weitergeleitet und porto
bestreitet dass beispielsweise dann kann
ja der kunde gar nicht wissen was stimmt
und deswegen ist ansprechpartner immer
nur der vertragspartner den unter druck
setzen und schlimmstenfalls sogar klagen
einreichen
wir haben natürlich konto oder auch
befragt die sagen uns vertragspartner
mit der kunden ist in diesem fall opodo
deswegen ist die erstattung auch an
opodo erfolgt kommt mir komisch vor
obwohl das ist ja kein reiseveranstalter
klar so kann man es natürlich machen und
tatsächlich sie sagen selbst es ist ja
wirklich für den kunden überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar wo das geld jetzt ist
eben und deswegen ist es auch immer ganz
wichtiges bezüge ist auch auf jede form
von gewährleistungs rechten eigentlich
auf jede vertragliche konstellation
oftmals ist es ja so ich wende mich an
den an irgendwie an meinen verkäufer
oder wen auch immer und der sagt ja da
müssen wir noch einen dritten fragen das
kann im innenverhältnis der
leistungsanbieter der leistungserbringer
kann das vielleicht so sein aber im
verhältnis zum kunden spielt immer nur
der eine rolle mit dem ich einen vertrag
habe und bitte immer nur an den wänden
und hier die vertragsverhältnisse müsste
man sich etwas genauer angucken
ich kenne jetzt diese
buchungsbestätigung in diesem fall
beispielsweise nicht aber david mal
reingucken wer ist denn ausweislich der
bestätigung derjenige der auch die
leistung erbringen muss der im grunde
genommen auch der wäre wenig verklagen
müsste und den spreche ich auch an
also sagt sich wirklich an dieser stelle
immer wieder es ist ganz ganz schwierig
mit zur reisebüros gerade auch mit
online reisebüros verträge oder
vereinbarungen einzugehen gerade auch
wenn viele online reisebüros haben
natürlich zum teil auch den
kundenservice eingestellt dann landet
man entweder in warteschleifen oder die
rufnummern funktionieren gar nicht mehr
es zeigt sich natürlich vielleicht sind
manchmal die online reisebüros ein wenig
günstiger aber wirklich meine appel und
meine empfehlung verkehren alle
zuschauer ist buchen sie direkt bei der
airline
sie ersparen sich jede menge ärger und
ich weiß nicht wann frau fleschutz jetzt
ihr geld zurück bekommt das ist halt
nervig
und tatsächlich mein appell nie bei
online reisebüros buchen immer direkt
bei der airline condor hat zumindest
versprochen die wollen sich jetzt mit
opodo in verbindung setzen dass die
rückerstattung schneller erfolgt dass es
immerhin etwas aber trotzdem ein ganz
ganz schwieriger fall